[Music]
i'm gonna lift up the top card this is
your card remember this card
[Music]
stop right there where you said stop was
where your card was
[Music]
i'm learning more stuff it's like
it's basically like magic because like
you start off here and then
at some point when you don't expect it
you'll get to another level
[Music]
it's constantly something going on
always busy always noise
[Music]
any mom who is raising their kids alone
is worried that their kids are going to
fall behind or not have enough of
something to reach
where they should in life as they grow
[Music]
there was like
some things actually like in third grade
that i went back and relearned and it
actually helped me a lot in the sixth
grade
one thing that really helped me is where
if you can't get it
you can get a hint or watch the videos
and he's using the khan academy i he
tells me that he gets to watch his
progress so he gets to see each step
that he takes how far he's getting in it
and that makes him motivated to keep
going and to get to the next level and
it's like instant gratification for him
him taking control of his learning and
just
seeing his success it gives him
his own
boost of confidence not just in the
classroom but at home
[Music]
i'm
extremely proud just seeing the little
person he's growing into and the pride
he has in himself always makes me feel
good because then i feel like i'm doing
something right as a parent you need
help i really like helping a lot besides
math and learning and all that that's
like one of my favorite things to do
[Music]